la parole est à notre collègue bernard
fournier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur premier
vice- messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait à la
ministre du travail et de l'emploi
la france est désormais reléguée en
queue de peloton européen concernant le
chômage et la création d'emplois en tout
plus de six millions et demi de
demandeurs d'emploi dans notre pays
souhaite plus 10% de la population
active contre 5,6 au royaume uni et 6 4
en allemagne
cette situation catastrophique touche
désormais toutes les classes d'âge et
toutes les catégories de la population
il n'ya plus que l'opposition la
république pour croire et une réelle et
significative inversion de la courbe du
chômage d'ici 2017
la seule véritable inflexion que nous
constatons dans cette politique
économique désastreuse aura consisté à
un glissement sémantique la question de
l'emploi est dorénavant urgentes alors
que jusqu'ici elle n'était qu'une
priorité mais les recettes sont les
mêmes contrats et des embauches de
fonctionnaires est aujourd'hui un plan
de formation irréaliste qui consiste à
transférer 500 mille chômeurs dans la
catégorie des pour inverser office est
artificiellement la courbe à laquelle le
chef de l'état a conditionné sa
candidature en 2017
ce plan d'urgence dont le coût est
évalué à 1 milliard d'euros n'est ni
plus ni moins que l'aveu public de
l'échec d'une politique
ne croyez vous pas monsieur le ministre
il est temps de changer de ligne
politique en encourageant le pays sur la
voie incontournable de la compétitivité
journée
merci la parole et au ministre en charge
des relations avec le parlement pour
répondre monsieur le président l'abs et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
bernard fournier d'abord effectivement
nous avons engagé ce pays sur le chemin
de la compétitivité parce qu'avec tu le
sais et ce avec le pacte de
compétitivité
nous avons fait en sorte pour la
première fois depuis plus d'une décennie
plus d'une décennie que la france et que
les nos entreprises retrouvent des
marges de compétitivité et marges de
profitabilité et que le coût du travail
dans notre pays soit inférieur à celui
du coût du travail en allemagne
je rappelle que ces chiffres nous les
avons ils sont constatables et nous
l'avons nous les avons mis en oeuvre
parce que justement ce n'était pas la
situation que nous avons trouvée
deuxièmement sans doute une autre
différence avec vous monsieur le
sénateur c'est la volonté de ce
gouvernement de s'engager sur la
formation de ces centaines de milliers
de nos compatriotes qui sont sortis de
nos du système éducatif sans formation
sans qualification et de fait sans
insertion et en faisant cela nous savons
que nous relevons un défi fondamental de
la politique de l'emploi en france tout
le savons parce que que cela est
possible parce que déjà en 2014 et en
nous avons mis en place des plans de
formation pour ces chômeurs de longue
durée
57% d'entre eux ayant bénéficié de cette
formation ont retrouvé un travail
six mois après alors comme notre
économie retrouve la capacité à créer
des emplois
comme cela vous a été rappelée à
l'instant il s'agit aujourd'hui de faire
en sorte que ces formations soient
d'abord adaptée aux métiers en tension
et vous êtes nombreux à souligner les
difficultés qui existent dans certains
secteurs de notre économie c'est aussi
pour faire en sorte que l'avenir nous
soyons présents dans l'avenir des
secteurs porteurs d'emplois que sont par
exemple la croissance verte et le numéro
conclu
je conclu monsieur le président en vous
disant que ce gouvernement prend ses
responsabilités il ne baisse pas les
bras devant le chômage
ils se mobilisent et ils vous demandent
aussi de vous mobiliser
monsieur fournier pour la réplique vient
votre réponse est tout sauf rassurante
monsieur ministre vos mesures ne sont
que de l'affichage elles trahissent est
également votre refus de prendre en
compte les réalités du monde
d'aujourd'hui
les recettes du passé ne permettent pas
d'engager de vraies réformes
structurelles des mesures aussi
coûteuses qu'inefficaces il est urgent
de réformer d'alléger les charges des
dorures le jeu carrère du témoin qui
préside je vous remercie
merci